Here's an interesting a certain sort of political
story is that it's a break.
This is a political show.
It's a break from the virus coverage.
And it's about Democratic New York Congresswoman
Alexandrea Castillo Cortez.
She's getting crushed by a portion of the
left, a portion of the left.
That widely supported her for a long time,
at least until recently.
And the reason AOC is getting crushed is she
is taking what she sees as a more pragmatic
approach to the progressive movement.
And it's a really, really interesting story
that has divided the online progressive left
over the last few days.
This all started because there are a whole
bunch of primary challenges by progressive
Democratic candidates against more centrist
Democratic incumbents.
AOC hasn't endorsed many of those progressive
challengers.
She's chosen a couple of sort of easy ones
in Texas and Illinois, where the opponents
are really conservative Democrats who oppose
abortion.
But otherwise, AOC has stayed out of a lot
of these races.
AOC has also had quite a bit of turnover in
her staff.
A lot of those sort of outspoken young progressive
activists that were working for AOC have been
replaced with some more moderate professional
political strategists, Democrats that often
work with incumbent Democrats.
Now, there are questions increasingly about
whether AOC campaigned enough for Bernie before
Super Tuesdays, results that that hurt Bernie.
And the second Super Tuesday and the third
Super Tuesday and the virus ultimately keeping
people at home.
And AOC has also publicly shifted from being
very antagonistic towards Nancy Pelosi, the
Democratic speaker of the House, to being
more publicly laudatory and positive towards
Nancy Pelosi.
And a lot of people have jumped on her for
this.
AOC has also jumped into criticizing Bernie
supporters for online harassment.
That's been mostly the purview of centrist
Democrats and Biden supporters and sort of
DNC folks.
But AOC has said, yeah, you know, a lot of
that online harassment is not good.
She said some of Bernie's allies are too conflict
based.
That also rubbed a lot of Bernie supporters
the wrong way.
AOC also launched a PAC earlier this year,
which is not looking to primary centrist Democrats.
It's focused on flipping red states to blue.
The goal of AOSIS PAC is not to find centrist
Democrats and replace them.
It's to find red seats and turn them blue,
replacing Republicans with Democrats.
Now, I have to tell you, this makes me see
AOC as much more clever and shrewd politically
as a political operative than I imagined you
guys.
Many of you criticize me occasionally for
saying, hey, you know, AOC has a lot of the
right ideas, but not the right political practicality,
not the right political approach.
I see that as changing here.
Now, there's lots of people that are furious
about this.
Tea Whitey host Janke Yuga has gone after
AOC for this.
A bunch of others have.
But let's think this through.
First of all, almost everyone changes when
they got elected.
And this is why I always say don't DFI or
glorify individual politicians.
They are all elected by the system we currently
have.
And essentially every single one of them,
to some degree it varies.
But to some degree, when they become elected
officials under that system, they will start
to really reinforce or defend to some degree
some elements of the system that got them
elected once they get into power.
That applies to just about everybody.
It doesn't mean that they flip and abandon
their values.
That's not what I'm saying.
But that's not the important analysis for
me.
The important analysis for me is that we just
got done talking about Bernie lost, not because
his ideas are bad, but because a lot of the
people around him are toxic because of his
relationship with those in positions of power,
because the country just isn't as overtly
left as Bernie Sanders.
For the last six weeks, we've been saying
many of us, the future of the progressive
movement.
Is in somebody with Bernie's sensibilities.
Bernie's values.
Many of Bernie's policy goals.
But who has a better team around them?
Fewer toxic people.
Better branding.
None of this democratic socialist stuff.
The revolution language is not particularly
useful to Bernie.
AOC isn't changing her political positions
here.
Her view on Medicare for all hasn't changed.
Her view on the Green New Deal hasn't changed.
She's changing her approach.
Maybe at least that's what it seems like.
This is what we've been talking about, guys.
We don't need someone who differs from Bernie
on core values.
Bernie has the right core values.
AOC shares Bernie's core values.
Nothing has changed as far as that goes.
AOC is doing exactly what Bernie didn't do.
AOC is doing something to get around what
ultimately led to Bernie getting crushed on
Super Tuesday and then more on Super Tuesday
2 and more on Super Tuesday 3.
People keep saying, hey, we need Bernie's
ideas with better framing, packaging and public
relations.
That's what AOC is leaning towards here.
AOC is looking to become a force for change
by building these relationships where in the
next six years, eight years, she could have
a long laundry list of legislative accomplishments.
She's working within the system to invoke
change.
Now, that's an area of disagreement.
Bernie has more of an approach of destroying
the system revolution and then rebuilding
it from the ground up.
Working within the system has gotten us many
important things.
Gay Marriage, Violence Against Women Act,
food stamps, Social Security, Consumer Financial
Protection Bureau, preexisting conditions,
coverage and being on your parents insurance
until age 26.
Labor laws, birth control.
Now, has it been enough?
No.
No way in hell has it also led to bad things.
Of course.
I mean, you know, look at the Iraq war.
The Iraq war is the epitome of working within
the system with centrist Democrats in great
part that got us the Iraq war.
But when I see AOC step away from some of
the absolutism of Bernie.
My feeling is this will help her get things
done rather than being able to say, we tried
this, but we failed.
We didn't actually get to do it.
I believe this better positions AOC to actually
get things done.
To me, this suggests AOSIS political instincts
are better than I thought.
I underestimated her political instincts until
I saw this.
I'm ready to get crushed, my friends.
I'm ready for people to disagree.
Tell me all the ways in which I am wrong.
But this this actually improves my opinion
of
AOC dramatically.